those epic proves and a lot of things
prove that people would like to to lose
weight if they could this is a fact and
the fat phobia community and the fat
activist Community doesn't want to hear
that but
those people have invented jobs for
themselves that's not a job being Fat's
not a job you invented a job I don't get
paid because I'm overweight I get paid
to do this
I mean it's not a job they invented a
job and by the way on on that
I mean to get paid for eating like like
the idea that you're just sitting there
eating and you're like I'm gonna be an
activist and that this Society at this
point is so broken that they fall for it
hey get your bag we'll get a few bags
get the one out of the drive through and
then get the money as well but that's
what we're doing here these are people
that have invented jobs
the person who is riding the fat phobic
quiz should be living in a tent